with kids back to school the days are
about to get a whole lot busier healthy
eating is not only important for kids
growth and development but research
suggests that it may have a positive
impact on learning and test scores as
well registered dietitian mia sin shares
healthy meal ideas to fuel students and
stay healthy this back to school season
hey las vegas now school is back in
session and i have some easy healthy
recipes to help fuel busy students
starting with the make ahead breakfast
option these are customizable chocolate
and vanilla overnight oats combining
half cup of oats one tablespoon of maple
syrup and chia seeds a half cup of
almond milk and one scoop of else
plant-powered complete nutrition shake
for kids in dreamy chocolate or creamy
vanilla which helps fill in nutrient
gaps for growing kids and can be enjoyed
on its own or mixed into recipes it's a
delicious kid-approved minimally
processed dairy milk alternative that's
low in sugar made with clean whole
plant-based ingredients like almonds
tapioca and buckwheat and without common
allergens like soy dairy and gluten
transfer to a jar place in the fridge
overnight and top with fresh fruit in
the morning
next build a better lunch box around
protein produce and whole grains in
creative ways these two lunches check
all your boxes for the taco box start
with black beans and cheese for protein
add whole grain tortillas and veggies
fresh cravings salsa is a great way to
get in a serving of veggies and is made
with a short list of organic whole food
ingredients find it chilled in the
produce section at walmart and food for
less in my mediterranean box cherry
tomatoes cucumber and arugula are the
veggies boro is the whole grain and for
protein i added roasted chickpeas and
creamy fresh cravings hummus which you
can find chilled in the produce section
at smith's it's made with a short list
of high quality ingredients like chilean
extra virgin olive oil non-gmo chickpeas
and savory tahini so besides protein it
also adds good fats and filling fiber
next stock open essentials to stay
healthy while heading back to school
prebiotics are a type of fiber found in
foods like bananas asparagus onions and
oats that can support digestive and
immune health by helping to nourish the
good bacteria in the gut life's first
naturals cal colostrum also contains
prebiotics as well as immune factors and
protective proteins that provide immune
and digestive health benefits to adults
and children over the age of one poppy
is a better for you prebiotic soda made
with real clean ingredients and around
one tablespoon of pure unfiltered apple
cider vinegar unlike traditional soda
it's low in calories and sugar with 20
calories or less and 5 grams of sugar or
less per can and comes in delicious
flavors like raspberry rose grapefruit
and ginger lime next incorporate
probiotics which are beneficial bacteria
that help support digestive and immune
health they're found in fermented foods
like sauerkraut and yogurt as well as
high quality probiotic supplements like
truebiotics which is comprised of a
proprietary blend of the two most
clinically studied types of good
bacteria finally i have an after-school
snack that will help you stay cool these
homemade frozen smoothie tubes are a
cool treat with benefits simply blend up
your favorite smoothie add them to
resealable pouches and freeze until set
i hope you enjoyed these tips and
recipes you can find them at my website
nutritionbymia.com
and nutritionbymia on instagram where i
also share meal ideas and nutrition tips
daily